chef quoi de bon menu aujourd'hui rini
soises rôti dindonneau sauce madère
de légumes et glace
vous nourrissez combien de bouches par
jour aux environs de 920 personnes
parce que vous faites des frites pour
tout ce petit monde ça représente
combien de kilos de pommes de terre 500
kg aux environs tu trouves que tu manges
bien
au moyen non ça dépend des fois on vous
fait peur
des fois
quelquefois c'est très bon
c'est pas bon
menu de demi-pension ou menu de cantine
manger à l'école en 1975 c'est le lot
d'un grand nombre d'écoliers on mange à
l'école parce que la maman travaille
parce que la maison est trop éloignée
parce que de plus en plus cela arrange
bien les parents pour l'enfant le
réfectoire la cantine c'est
l'apprentissage de la vie pas toujours
drôle même si la soupe est bonne manger
à l'école c'est d'abord être entre
copains mais c'est aussi pour l'enfant
une préfiguration de la société où il
sera complètement intégré quelques
années plus tard avec tout ce que cela
demande d'observation l'égoïste le
gourmand le picassiette le petit qui
deviendra grand mangeur de pseudo caviar
dans les parties ou bien un grand
silencieux devant des potages cimenté et
puis les autres qui apprennent la
durloie de la jungle manger ou alors se
passer de manger parce que le camarade
d'à côté a déjà un sérieux coup de
fourchette il y a de cela à la cantine
les premiers jours
est-ce que tu préfères manger à la
cantine ou manger chez toi mange à la
cantine à la cantine je suis mort
c'est meilleur
mais je trouve qu'on a une entente
familière un peu mieux quelquefois
est-ce que tu aimes manger à la cantine
on est plus
avec les copains quoi alors on peut
s'amuser alors pourquoi aimes-tu la
cantine
[Musique]
on s'amuse mieux tu lances pas des
boulettes de pain un petit camarade des
fois non
donner à boire quand il a pas soif
après on apprend à servir à partager
entre soi c'est comme une petite famille
créée en dehors de la cellule familiale
alors manger à l'école devient enfin un
plaisir
[Musique]